hello everyone and welcome to today's
live broadcast rabbit breeding standards
and practices
presented by Catherine Cavanaugh we are
excited to bring you this educational
web seminar presented by elaborates to
learn more about my fruits
please visit my fruits calm I am
Christina Mahalo collaborates and I'll
be your moderator for today's events
before we begin I would like to remind
everyone that this event is interactive
we encourage you to participate by
submitting as many questions as you want
at any time you want during the
presentation just click on the green Q&A
button located in the lower left of the
presentation window and type your
question into the box that appears on
the screen well answer as many questions
as we have trained for at the end of the
presentation also please notice that you
will be viewing the presentation in the
slide window to enlarge the window just
click on the screen icon located on the
lower right if you have trouble seeing
or hearing the presentation please click
on the support button at the top right
of the presentation window or use the
Q&A button to let us know if you're
having a problem now I'd like to
introduce Katherine Cavanaugh Katherine
Cavanaugh is a UC Davis graduate with a
BS in animal science she is currently an
I cook coordinator at UT Southwestern
Medical Center
prior to her position at UT Southwestern
she worked as a breeding coordinator
managing a breeding colony of Dutch
belted rabbits she has spoken at the
National a last meetings on the topics
of establishment of novel I cook
guidelines for evaluation of mild
traumatic brain injury devices for mice
and rats an early pregnancy
determination and daily observations of
fetal development via ultrasonographer
in dutch belted rabbits please join me
in welcoming Katherine I will now turn
the present
never to her thank you Christina and hi
everyone welcome thank you for tuning in
today I'll be discussing basic rabbit
breeding and also some tips and tricks
and these tricks are for rabbits and not
for kids
okay so a little bit about my personal
experience I've read Dutch belt rabbits
we use natural breedings so we didn't
use hormone manipulation or artificial
insemination of us all natural breeding
pairs I mean we used offspring to use as
replacement breeders we use ultrasound
imaging in order to determine pregnancy
and we weaned rabbits at 28 to 30 days
so going over a little bit of glossary
before we get started these are common
terms I'm going to be using about the
presentation a doe is a female rabbit a
buck is a male rabbit Kindle means when
a rabbit gives birth an S box is a box
that you place into a dose enclosure
near the time that she's going to Kindle
and this is what she's going to build
her nest into and what she will Kindle
into you and a kit is a juvenile rabbit
okay so some environmental factors these
are some steps you can take to set up
your breeding room to increase
productivity first is life cycle you're
gonna want to mimic longer days which
are conducive for rabbit breeding so
you're going to want to set up your life
cycle to be a 16 hour light and an 8
hour dark cycle diet I know that diet
isn't really an environmental factor but
it is something that is in your control
to help increase overall productivity by
ensuring that you're breeding rabbits as
well as your older rabbits are getting
appropriate nutrition so in our colony
are breeding dough's and our younger
rabbits we're on
same diet and then for our breeding
buffs as well as our older rabbits there
were over a few months of age were on a
more traditional high-fiber rabbit diet
so I definitely suggest contacting your
feed vendor of the turn normally working
with to discuss options that would be
best suited to the needs and ages of
your colony also providing Hey Luce hey
we would typically give to our breeders
and our kids we notice that the kids had
trouble with hay cubes so we opted to
give them loose hay and then for older
rabbits we would give the cubes also
there's been some work done on
evaluating the benefits of placing males
in the same room as your female breeding
rabbits your breeding dose and also and
their effects on being receptive to
breeding and also giving them visual
contact has been shown to increase that
receptive receptivity to breeding as
well
so we use this in our colony so we would
have our breeding doze facing our
breeding Bucks with visual contact in
closer proximity and speaking
anecdotally this seemed to work very
well we had very high reception
receptive rates when we would pair our
doze with our bucks so it is something
that I would suggest doing okay so
enrichment crowd favorites by far or
anything that made noise especially sort
of metal items that would cling against
their enclosure door inside their
enclosure so we use hanging metal chains
and rattles and this was just a fix of
their cage door so it was easy for
cleaning it just became a permanent
fixture within the cage that went
through cage washing with the cage
whisks were another great item I bought
whisks from a chef's supply warehouse
sort of website so they were very
inexpensive and these that either be
hanging on the
or just be placed on the floor of the
enclosure either way if they were great
as least hey feeders as well as even
without hay in them the rabbits love to
just sort of nudge these around or sort
of jingle them against the cage door we
also used auditory enrichment we had a
stereo within our room that we would
play CDs or had an auxilary hookup so we
could plug in our phones the you do want
to be very careful with the music that
you select rabbits like a very calm
setting so we would play like classical
music or new-age music the Enya Pandora
station was a common station on in our
rabbit room it was nice and calm
classical music if it has a lot of sort
of ups and downs and crescendos and
things like that it can be a little
startling so just be mindful of the sort
of music that you're playing in the room
at the very least it provided a white
noise background within the room so
things such as doors opening or doors
closing or I mentioned those noisemakers
sort of clanging without the music it
could provide a little bit of a startle
to the rabbits but with the music on it
provided a nice background noise that
sort of kept everyone in a calm sort of
spirit if you are going to use music
definitely consult the guide on kind of
provisions that they have about music
and noise and rooms I've included some
notes here they do say keep it below 85
decibels make sure that it is the using
music as part of your enrichment program
so something that would make perhaps
need to be approved by your AIA cook or
just within an SOP that you maintain so
that it's an actual part of your
enrichment program documented and also
recommending to turn it off at the end
of the Working Day so that's what we did
we would comment in the more
and turn on the stereo and have it
playing during the hours that we were
working on-site and then we would go
home for the day our last thing would be
to turn off the stereo okay so getting
into breeding sexual maturity so I'm
using the abbreviation DB that just
means touch belts so for Dutch belt
females sexual maturity was about four
months of age and for Dutch about males
it was about five months of age now for
larger breeds you're going to see more
delayed sexual maturity time line so for
instance in New Zealand white you may
not get sexual maturity for your females
until perhaps five months and for your
males even perhaps closer to six months
much of the information I'll be
presenting today is applied to rabbits
in general it's not breed specific
information but if I do have things that
are breed specific I'll make sure to
make a note that I'm speaking
specifically to touch belts
so for these ages of sexual maturity
four and five months is more specific to
touch belts okay another key of
maintaining a successful breeding colony
is record-keeping this is going to keep
you organized it's also going to help
you keep track of your breeders
performance to help you make smart
decisions about selective breeding who
you want to choose offspring of to be
future breeders and who perhaps you want
to consider taking out of your program
so the in the indications they have in
black here are more of your calendar
dates that you want to keep things
organized with and then the indications
in red are your more performance records
that you want to keep so starting with
date of breeding this is exactly what it
sounds like it's the day that you pair
your rabbits together that they're going
to be breeding when you pair them
together you're going to observe them
and give them a copulation score a
copulation score means if there was a
successful copulation observed during
the breeding grounds so I used a
copulation system of 1 or 0 it was
basically a passive fail grade if I saw
that when I carried the rabbits together
there was a
successful copulation I would give them
a score of one if I paired them together
and there was no successful kind of
breeding event then I would give them a
score of zero date of pregnancy
evaluation so this is going to be
determined by your date of breeding and
it's going to be dependent on the method
of pregnancy determination that you're
using when you do your pregnancy
determination you're then going to give
a pregnancy score and this is just a yes
or no whether they're pregnant or
they're not pregnant the date of nest
box placement so you're gonna place your
nest box within the enclosure
twenty-eight days post copulation so
it's going to be 28 days after your
breeding date and so the date of nest
box latent placement is again going to
be determined by your date of breeding
your data of kindling is will be
dictated by your date of breeding but
kindling it is a little bit more of a
range it's not a definite date so you
always have to kind of mark a range on
your calendar of expected dates of
kindling based off of the day that you
bred the rabbit a performance record at
kindling is to notate the size of the
litter that the doe had and the date of
reap reading okay so this is going to be
now dictated by your date of kindling
you're going to want to allow an
appropriate resting period for your
dough between the date that she Kindles
and the day that you reap read her and
then when you do read breed her you're
going to want to give a copulation score
and again this just goes down the
Cascade of dates again and then date of
weaning your date of weaning is going to
be dictated by your date of kindling to
be about 28 to 30 days after kindling
you could go ahead and wean and you're
going to want to notate a mortality rate
so just like you notated a litter size
at the time of kindling you're going to
want to notate the litter size at the
time weaning to determine a sort of
mortality rate that there was okay so
continuing on with breeding so now
you're ready to start breeding always
bring the dough to the buck you
either bring the dough to the Buffs
enclosure and place our in with the buck
or you can use a neutral space if you
use a neutral space I would suggest you
grab the buck first place them in the
neutral area and then go back and grab
your dough and place her in that neutral
space with the buck as soon as you care
the rabbits together watch them closely
rounds of copulation will go very fast
and you don't want to miss anything so
I'm going to give you a breakdown of
what a successful round of copulation is
so first you'll probably see a little
bit of chasing behaviour this is the
buck chasing the doe then he's going to
mount her from behind you're gonna see
some rapid pelvic movement and then your
finale is going to be the Bucks feet are
going to buckle under him a bit and he's
going to give a fall to the side or a
fall backwards and as soon as you see
that sort of feet buckling in a like a
temporary paralysis and a fall that's
going to give you the signal to go ahead
and give a positive copulation score
that's going to notice a successful
copulation when hearing rabbits together
I do suggest leaving them together for a
few rounds of copulation this is going
to increase your chances of conception
rabbits are induced ovulate errs so how
they obviate they of you late based off
of stimulation they feel during
copulation so it's the act of copulation
itself that makes them ovulate so the
more stimulation you have the better
chances you're going to have for
conception also obviously more sperm
deposit by the buck something you want
to watch closely during pairing is signs
of aggression this is going to be signs
of aggression by the dough towards the
buck I've never experienced aggression
from a buck towards a doe typically the
Bucks are very excited for reading day
and the doze are most of the time
excited
sometimes they can be observed to be a
little bit aggressive which means
they're just not receptive at that time
typically scientific there's a
difference between chasing an aggression
though just because do you see some
chasing behavior doesn't mean that you
should pull the dough out of the
enclosure that's pretty typical at the
start of a copulation round so but
actual aggression she'll do an
about-face and face the buck and will
try and start kind of biting at him and
showing aggressive behavior at that
point you'll take her out of the
enclosure return her to her own space
and away at least one day before trying
to pair her again okay so breeding still
continue continuing buck performance so
there is something called buck fatigue
this is basically the point in the day
where a buck would reach sexual
exhaustion if he does reach exhaustion
then you will wait and pare him the next
day kind of give him about a 24 hours
resting period and you'll note buck
exhaustion because they will no longer
mount a female they may act a little
disinterested if she's in the cage
that's going to notate that he's sort of
be done for the day and you're gonna
give them want to give him a little bit
of resting time a typical ratio of buck
to doe ratio for Dutch belt - my
experience has been about a three to one
ratio so I would breed about tendo's
within a day and I would use about three
bucks in order to service those tendo's
so Reeb reading of dose doze will be
receptive to breeding after kindling
soon after kindling but I do not suggest
Rhea breeding right away because you
will wear out your breeders and your
are very important sources so you don't
want to wear out an experienced mother
you want to try to keep her as active as
possible until her performance starts to
decrease so allow them appropriate
resting time between the time that they
Kindle and the time that you reread them
a minimum of 14 days is recommended and
my experience leaves closer to a 16 to
18 day resting period so in essence she
will be nursing her current litter while
she's just dating her next litter so if
you are using a practice where you're
reading while she's still nursing a
litter make sure you're weaning her
first litter at you know that close to
28 day mark so that you're then allowing
her again time between when you weaned
her first litter and then she's going to
be kindling her next litter before we
breeding always do a body condition
score evaluation some of the challenges
the Ducks felt rabbits there they're
about a medium to kind of smaller breed
so tip sometimes the resting period
would not even up to 18 days they just
wouldn't be ready for rereading so you
want to take an inventory of if she is
she going to have the body resources to
not only finish her lactation of her
current litter but finish the gestation
of that next litter and lactation of
that litter that she's the second litter
that she'll Kindle so doing a body
condition score will allow you to
evaluate if you want to reread her at
that time if you notice that she's she
doesn't seem to have the body resources
to be reread at that time I like to keep
a few rabbits on retainer and pulling
sort of a substitute and breed a
substitute and allow that particular
deal a little bit more resting time okay
so moving on a pregnancy determination
the primary method of pregnancy
determination for rabbits is palpation
this is the manual feeling of the lower
abdomen using your
and so you slide your hands under the
rabbit and feel in its lower abdominal
area and what you're feeling for are
sort of great like structures these
sorts of round nodules in the lower
abdomen and that's going to indicate a
presence of kids a litter
[Music]
it does require training there is quite
a bit of a learning curve to get a hand
for palpation and there can be a
challenge with accuracy
I tried palpation many many times and I
never really developed quite the hand
for it so I was very fortunate that we
had an ultrasound unit on site at the
institution that I could kind of explore
using for pregnancy determination which
is what I did and that was our method of
pregnancy determination that we use so
ultrasound allows for early and accurate
pregnancy determination about days five
to seven post copulation it does require
a bit of training to train your eye as
to what you're looking for when you're
ultrasounding a rabbit where your
ultrasounding kind of where you position
the probe and the structures are looking
forward to indicate that a rabbit is
pregnant but I found that it was much
easier to train my eye for ultrasound
rather than my hand for palpation a
drawback of using ultrasound is that the
equipment is expensive you'll definitely
have to budget it into your program but
early and accurate pregnancy results are
something that's going to be invaluable
to breeders when you're breeding time is
money so if you're able to determine
pregnancy at five to seven days and
maybe rebreathe a dough that's not
pregnant versus waiting ten to fourteen
days it makes a big difference okay so I
want to elaborate a little bit on the
process of using an ultrasound in
rabbits for pregnancy determination
there are some existing sources out
there which can serve as an excellent
starting point but I found that some of
the images were a little bit hard to
determine
what exactly was you you were looking
for and also it didn't have a very
user-friendly guide of how to prep the
rabbit for ultrasound and how obscure
position the probe and where to position
it on the rabbit so I'll go through and
share some of my tips so first you want
to restrain the rabbit you can see here
in a picture it's an a dorsal recumbent
see what you don't see in the picture is
that the restrainer has the head tucked
under its arm so it's basically like a
typical kind of football hold that you
do for a rabbit except that they're
belly-up
so restrain the rabbit you're going to
want to shave a small area apply your
ultrasound gel and position your probe
it's an essential orientation so it's
basically kind of parallel with their
teeth line
okay so development starts more caudal
and moves a bit more cranial so for the
purposes of early pregnancy
determination within you know like I
said about that one week mark you're
going to want to use the pelvic bone
there excuse me yes the pubic bone and
the most caudal teat line as your area
of interest to shave and position your
probe if you're evaluating sort of fetal
development later in the gestation cycle
then you want to use the first and
second most caudal teats as your point
of interest okay so starting at day five
figure one this is what first of all
you're going to want to look to locate
when you're imaging it's the uterine
lumen all of the vesicles basically all
of the action is happening in the
uterine lumen so that's what you want to
isolate first you'll notice that it sort
of has two lines and then an ant echo
it's sort of lumen to it and then in
figure two what you're going to be
looking for within that lumen are these
circular vesicles there
an echogenic ring around them with it an
echo etc at day five these vesicles are
very small they're about 0.3 centimeters
in diameter day five is early in
gestation and can be challenging to
locate these vesicles but if you keep
this image in mind figure two I'm gonna
flip to day six you can see what a
drastic difference it is and it kind of
how much easier on day six it is to pick
up these vesicles they're larger in size
they've grown to about point four
centimeters in diameter they have an
anechoic center and an echogenic ring
the difference in like the light they're
they're picking up is more drastic at
day six than you saw at day five and
figure two this is another example now
when you have the probe positioned on
the rabbit the vesicles will sort of
what we call the wink at you and it's
basically you'll see that figure - the
darker portion in the center isn't as
drastic as in Figure one but if you were
to see something like this a figure two
if you were to wiggle your probe a
little bit I'll kind of get on if you
were to just wiggle your pro from side
to side you may see that the light
difference would become more drastic and
you would see a kind of a vesicle blink
or like I said wink at you so if you do
see something that you think is it
vesicle go ahead and keep your probe in
the same position and sort of just move
side to side and so you can kind of
catch that a better angle I should
mention that when you see these vesicles
this is what is determining that the
rabbit is pregnant so as soon as you see
these vesicles you can move on to the
next rabbit and start the process okay
so day seven and ultrasound so figure
one I've kind of outlined a structure
between these orange lines that the
yellow arrow is pointing at this is
actually the point of implantation along
the uterine wall which is a very
interesting structure to observe so at
this point the vesicle is actually
implanted and you can see that there are
two vesicles present in Figure one the
average size at day seven is
close to point six centimeters in
diameter figure two you'll see a green
arrow pointed to sort of a shaded part
within the vesicle and that's the start
of a formation of placental tissue so
they ate very easy to determine vesicles
in day eight as well and you can see
that the shading portion has become much
larger this is the placental tissue
developing and you can actually start
it's sort of start to cleave in on
itself as indicated with the blue arrows
and these vesicles are much larger in
size they're actually getting close to
about one centimeter in diameter at this
point so these are your days that you
would want to evaluate the rabbit for
pregnancy determination I do have a few
more images I want to show you out of
interest to show you if you may remember
I said palpation could be done starting
at day ten to 14 of copulation so I want
to show you what development looks like
up to day 14 just to show you how much
development actually happens by the time
that you would be able to even use
palpation as a method to determine if
they were pregnant so this is these
images are representative of development
at day nine and ten figure one is day
nine as indicated with the red arrow
it's pointing to an embryo becomes
visible by day nine figure two is from
day ten of gestation and it the blue
arrow is actually pointing to an
umbilical connection between the embryo
and the placental tissue day eleven is a
really exciting day for ultrasounding we
it's the first day that a heartbeat is
visible
I always thought of ultrasounding as
sort of getting a sneak peek at the kits
up and coming so observing a heartbeat
was really exciting
the heart is about 0.2 centimeters in
diameter its caliber and figure one
between the two a calipers and in figure
two I have a yellow arrow pointing to
sort of the
echogenic sort of circular structure
that's within sort of the middle of the
embryo and the chest cavity so day
twelve and thirteen in the day figure
one day twelve photo the blue arrow you
can see the amniotic sac outlining
embryo at this point in day thirteen the
blue arrow again pointing to an amniotic
sac in the yellow arrow you can actually
start to see the formation of a mess
muscular skeletal structure at this
point and day fourteen this is the last
image image these are the last images
I'll be sharing with you you can see the
development of four limbs by day 14 as
well as you start to see some
sophistication within the cranial
structures the purple arrow is pointing
to an eye socket okay so to wrap up with
ultrasound we had a really interesting
case of resorption so I want to point
out that we didn't ultrasound our
rabbits every day we did a special
project with two groups of gestating
those that we we had we thought it would
be interesting and valuable to chronicle
fetal development from the time of
pregnancy determination up to day 28
when we placed the nest box into the
enclosure that way if we ever wanted to
ultrasound a female to sort of evaluate
the health of the literature development
of the litter we would know what normal
development looked like and so we could
kind of compare what you know our stock
photos at a certain day looks like
versus if we were evaluating a rabbit in
lifetime so when we were sort of doing
that project we were imaging a
particular doe and from day 7 to 14 it
was completely normal development
vesicles were determined early on
embryos for president and then day 15
and 16 we solved all empty vesicles and
then day 17 we continued to image her on
day 17 we noted one life beetus so it
was a fetus that we missed on day 15 and
16 and then at the end of her gestation
cycle she did
only Kindle one kit and without the use
of ultrasound we would have been left
wondering why the rabbit of litter
bearing species that only Kindle one kit
kind of how that happened but because we
had been ultrasounding her we actually
knew it was because of the case of
resorption it wasn't because she got
pregnant with only one kit initially it
was that she was pregnant with a litter
resorbed all that one kit and that's
what she ended up with at the end of
gestation so some final conclusions
about ultrasound it provides an accurate
and efficient method of pregnancy
determination it's a useful tool for
evaluating fetal development as well as
health status and it provides insightful
information about your dose performance
as I just explained with their case of
resorption okay so moving away from
pregnancy determination and getting back
on track with gestation and kindling
gestation a typical range of gestation
for a rabbit is 29 to 35 days I know
that that's a bit of a wide range from
personal experience are big days for
kindling were 30 to 32 days into
gestation and our most popular period
was the dark period between day 30 and
day 31 PC is post copulation nest fox
placement so you want to place the nest
box into the enclosure on day 28 post
copulation so 28 days and into her
gestation cycle day 28 you don't really
want to place it in earlier because she
will just use that box sort of as a
latrine area which is undesirable and
you don't want to place it in any later
because you want to give her enough time
to prepare her nest and then you know
actually Kindle her litter into the nest
box so day 28 has been widely accepted
as the date to place the nest box into
the enclosure
you'll fill the nest box with soft
bedding and I like to provide loose hay
in the enclosure at this time as well or
ensure that they had least hay available
in the enclosure at the
that I was putting the nest box in a lot
of the dough's would take that loose hay
and actually bring it into the nest box
as part of nesting material and it was
sort of them foraging for nesting
material and bring it into the nest box
was just facilitated positive nest
building behavior per the animal Animal
Welfare Act and nest box with clean
nesting materials must be provided for a
doe with a litter so it's actually built
into the radiations that a nest box be
provided rabbits will pull fur from
their chests and put it in the nest box
if you observe this she is building a
nest outside of the nest box
I would suggest moving the nest box to
where she's building the nest and
putting that fur that she's pulled
inside of the nest box this will
hopefully queue her in that she's
supposed to be using this box as as the
place to Kindle in and be building her
nest so expected litter size for our
Dutch belts we had an average number of
about seven kits per litter six to seven
we did have some that would consistently
have higher numbers we had some that
would have closer to ten kits
consistently well we had some that would
more err on the side of about six so it
averaged to about a number of seven as
an average for New Zealand are your
larger breeds such as New Zealand whites
you'll see this litter number increase I
believe for New Zealand White's have
read a figure of about eight to fourteen
kits as to be an expected litter size
okay nest box checks and handling so
after your doe Kindles you want to
incorporate nest box checks as a daily
part of your routine
this can be twofold one you're observing
that they are developing and that
they're being fed and secondly you can
start to handle them and this promotes a
socialization program that you're
starting early on that has been shown to
be beneficial and have lasting effects
as rabbits develop and they'll be more
used to human contact if you start that
socialization very
it'll have lasting effects later in
their life
Dutch boats are known to be a bit more
wild a bit more of a difficult lab
subject than their New Zealand
counterparts so as a Dutch belt breeder
it was really on a mission to break that
stereotype and just make the nicest
Comus Dutch belts in the business and
our socialization program definitely
helped to accomplish that so for kid
observations you want to observe that
they're fed or not fed so a federal that
will be easy to affect kit will be easy
to pick out they'll be plump and
appearance
they'll have sort of a rounded abdomen
shape if you were to look at them from
the back sort of from the rump
they'll have sort of their belly will be
bowed out on each side and they'll have
theirs thing will have a smooth
appearance to it not said you're gonna
see that they have a flat or even kind
of sunken in abdomen and they're gonna
have wrinkled skin the reason their skin
is going to be wrinkled is because
they're dehydrated when you're doing
your checks you also want to count your
litter each day so you want to get an
initial litter account starting day one
and then every day they're on you want
to count and make sure that a kit isn't
sort of roaming around in the nest box
away from the huddle hypothermia is a
kind of a big threat to kids so you want
to ensure that they are within the nest
box and that they are cuddled with their
other litter mates for heat insulation
also if you count and you notice that
one of the kids has died since the last
nest box check you want to remove them
from the nest box immediately so as
you're observing them this is your
opportunity to go ahead and start
socializing them so you want to start
handling them as soon as day one this is
a bit controversial whether you can
start handling them as as early as day
one or if you want to kind of let not
kind of scare the dough and wait a few
days before going to handle them our
breeders were very familiar with us the
those working with them so we went in as
soon as day 1 always using blood hands
to handle the kits without problems of
those sort of rejecting their litter
that was not the case so we would go in
as soon as day 1 we would pick each one
up individually conduct our health
observation and then we would orient it
in different positions in our hands that
are turning over in your hand and touch
each of its feet I sort of just hold it
for a little while and when the kids are
very Scourby so when you're holding them
make sure you're folding them over the
mess box don't hold them from sort of a
great height over the floor you're gonna
want to hold them sort of over the nest
box because they are very squirmy okay
so rabbits can be very successful foster
moms successful fostering you do want to
fuss if you do decide to foster I would
suggest try to foster earlier rather
than later some of the reasons you would
be interested in fostering is that if
you start to see a size disparity
between your litter so basically maybe
one to two kits will be falling behind
in size versus the other ones because
they are competing for the teeth and
maybe not getting as much access as
other kids in the litter so you may want
to foster to sort of even out litter
sizes to allow those smaller rabbits a
better chance at access and overall
survival so in the sized avarage
disparage becomes drastic very soon so
that's why I suggest kind of trying to
foster within the first few days if
that's the route you're going to go so
when you are placing a new kit into
their new nest box distract the DOE a
little bit you can go ahead and place a
treat in her enclosure at this time
maybe give her her hay for the day at
that time rub a little bit of the
bedding from the nest box that they're
being transferred to on the kid or if
there is a bit of urine available you
can rub it on
kit as well up urine from the dough rub
it on the kit and then place it into the
nest box try to when you're fostering
kids try to choose a kit that is of a
similar size to the litter that you're
fostering it to so like I said if
there's a kit that's sort of flowing
behind and developing you may not
necessarily always want to choose that
smaller kit as the one you want to
foster out you may want to if you're
fostering it to a litter of even larger
kits than the the original litter then
you may want to choose one of the larger
kits of the litter and choose that as
the one that you're fostering out so
advantages of fostering so why you
foster evening out litter sizes this can
accommodate breeders with larger litters
litters but have higher mortality rates
by the time that they're weaning their
litters so I had a rabbit consistently
had about 10 kits per litter which is a
sizable litter for a Dutch belt and but
she had problems keeping all of those
kits to leading whereas I had another
doe that had consistently lower litters
but was an excellent foster mom so I
would make sure to keep those two
dough's within the same breeding group
and then when it came time that dough
would have about 10 kits the other dough
would have six kids
I would take two of the kits from the
litter of ten and add its that litter of
six and that would make an equal litter
size of eight for both of those dough's
and that trick worked really well so
moving on to weaning I suggests weaning
and group housing as one step so the
minimum ages of weaning is 28 days we
weaned between 28 and 30 days when we
wean we would pair siblings of the same
sex together into their new enclosure if
we had an odd number of rabbits in the
litter we would pair them with the
another litter of the same gender
so from litter a and litter B there's
odd numbers there's
mail from litter a left over in a mail
from litter be left over we would put
them in the same enclosure we didn't
notice any difference between successful
pairings of actual genetic siblings
versus ones that we had just paired
together at the time of weaning at that
point they're young enough that they get
accustomed to the group housing and that
sort of genetic difference doesn't make
a impact long-term so our most common
results of pair housing were successful
pairings but most rabbits that were
paired together at weaning stay
peacefully paired until the time that we
shift out our rabbits we shipped out our
rabbits at the age of about 5 to 6
months of age we provided multiple
enrichment items within the enclosure as
well as provided enough hay for both
providing enough resources for the both
rabbits decrease the amount of
competition that there was like over
enrichment items or perhaps over a hate
cube just go ahead and provide you know
two even three in there to decrease the
competition so we didn't have to
separate occasionally on reasons for
separation were excessive chasing that
did not resolve with a dominance being
established dominance and pair housing
is not something that should be frowned
upon
it actually works to an advantage if
they do establish some sort of a
hierarchy between the pair so pairs that
struggle to establish dominance would
engage in the sort of constant sort of
chasing behavior they would sometimes
now to each other and then chase and
chase and chase so if we've noticed that
excessive chasing even if it didn't get
to the level of aggression but just that
dominance was not being established over
a few days then we would separate those
rabbits so another sign for separation
is aggression is aggression they'll do
an about-face to each other and they'll
try to fight each other or they'll go
into this sort of boxing behavior or
their rear up on their back legs and
then sort of fight with their front paws
and at that point when you see
aggressive behavior you'll want to
separate any time we stop separate
rabbits we
would no taint on their cage card the
date of separation and the reason why
they were separated and then males first
females in a group house settings so we
had successful pairings of both male
dutch belts as well as female dutch
belts the females tended to show signs
of dominance or aggression before males
and this was closely associated the
timing of sexual maturity I mean I did
mention that we shipped males out at
about 5 to 6 months of age so full
disclosure males do reach sexual
maturity about you know five months of
age for Dutch belts so we may have seen
increased success for males because we
were shipping them out at the time of
around the time of sexual maturity
although I will say even the male's that
we shipped out at later times like
closer to the six-month mark when they
would have sexually matured about
perhaps a month previous to that we
still did see successful pairings so
some acknowledgments I'd like to
acknowledge absorption systems
that's the institution that I worked at
as a breeding coordinator managing the
staff felt rabbit colony that I've been
speaking about I hope you can gather
from this presentation how kind of close
rabbit breeding is my heart and I'll
forever be grateful to absorption
systems for the opportunity that they
gave me managing that colony also the
images provided for the ultrasound
portion of the presentation were
captured on equipment at absorption
systems and then here are some helpful
references for some of the information
presented today thank you everyone so
much for tuning in I think we have some
time for question and answers if we want
to go over some of the questions that
we're receiving
Thank You Catherine for that informative
presentation it's time for the Q&A
session if you have a question you'd
like to ask please do so now just click
on the green Q&A button at the lower
left of the presentation window type
your question into the box that appears
on the screen and click the send button
will answer it as many of your questions
as you have time for let's get started
our first question of the day asks when
you say when you say you leave dose and
Buck's together for multiple rounds of
copulation how many do you expect to see
hi okay thank you for the question um so
when I say multiple rounds of
calculation I mean at least two rounds
perhaps three rounds once you see two to
three rounds you can take the dough back
to her original enclosure excellent
thank you for that informative answer
our second question how long should you
leave Bucks and those together when
breeding that
I'm sorry I'm catching up on the
question I think it was how long should
you leave bucks and does together when
breeding them so like I said it's a good
follow-up question to the last one so
for two to three rounds of copulation
you'll want to observe them for a few
minutes I would say up to about a 10
minute period would be sufficient for
observing them at that point after 10
minutes you're probably not going to see
more action so even if you just see one
round of copulation I would separate at
that time hopefully you would have seen
about two rounds of population without
to a 10-minute period thank you how did
you react when handling her kicks
okay so doe how does she react when
handling kits she so like I said our
breeders were very familiar with the
staff that did our nest Fox checks which
I think worked to our advantage so it
may be helpful to establish one to two
people that do your nest box checks so
they've reacted really well I think you
can take that as an opportunity to spend
a little time with your breeder as well
I mean yes Fox checks don't have to just
be about the nest box that can be a time
when you introduce the treat tier to
your breeder you know greet her I said
hello to her I don't have babies a
little crazy but you know greet your
your breeding doe first you know give
her her hey give her a treat and then go
ahead and proceed with the nest box
check
wonderful thank you so much and how long
do the kids stay in the nest box so
rabbits will open their eyes at about
ten to fourteen days of age at that
point you may start to see some
exploration outside of the nest box
definitely between two to three weeks of
age is the point in which you're going
to see the most exploration outside the
nest box for the age of three weeks they
are fully mobile inside in and out of
the nest box thank you for that and it
looks like we only have time for this
last question how much betting should be
added to the nest box I think the
question was how much betting is in the
nest box I I didn't use an exact
measurement of how much betting I was
adding to the nest box if I had to
estimate I would say about two inches
worth my suggestion for the betting for
the nest box when choosing a betting to
fill your nest box you want something
that has sort of a natural volume to it
already
I found that vendors were very open to
sending some samples initially for us to
sort of try which ones were going to be
more successful than others one of our
least successful ones was sort of a they
were sort of paper square chips and they
just didn't have much natural volume to
them they kind of just laid flat within
the nest box whereas another one was a
more sort of
red natural fibrous materials almost as
if like cardboard had sort of been like
gone through a wood chipper
and that had a some natural volume when
you hold it in your hand when you held
it in your hand and also create a sort
of a luminous nesting material within
the box as well I once again like to
thank Catherine Cavanaugh for her
presentation do you have any final
comments Catherine thank you everyone I
hope you learned some new information
and I'm very happy I got to share some
knowledge on this subject so go out and
be successful
call me managers of your rabbit breeding
colony Thank You Catherine I would also
like to thank our sponsor elaborates for
making today's educational whip as
possible before we go I want to let
everyone know that today's webcast will
be available for on-demand viewing for
three months from today's live event you
will receive an email from lab roots
when the webcast is available for replay
please share that announce that with
your colleagues who may have missed
today's live events that's all for now
thank you for joining up joining us and
we hope to see you again here soon at
Lavery's good bye